everyone knows Brightside the catchy
titles and irresistible thumbnails
promising to guess our age or tell us
our IQ and lucky for us they post three
times every single day ensuring that
there is always something to wash from
them this formula of high volume and um
sensational headlines has worked wonders
for bite site allowing them to grow from
nothing to thirty five million
subscribers and 6.5 billion views in
just three years
but this merely scratches the surface of
the Brightside Empire so here's the
other side
starting off bright site is owned by a
company called assault publishing I
started by talking about bright said as
this was a channel that I was most
familiar with but you guys are probably
familiar with many of their other
channels as well considering that all of
the channels are quite massive the sole
publishing are the people behind
five-minute crafts salmon Stanga riddles
avocado couple slick slime Sam
dude land and of course actually
happened they actually operate over 100
channels that have a collective 420
million subscribers their videos spend
18 different languages and allowed them
to produce 2700 videos every single
month or 90 videos every single day
given all of this it only makes sense
that we try to estimate how much they
actually make from all of these channels
most of the videos are generic
entertainment videos and have little
educational value so they're CPM is
likely quite low at two to three dollars
the CPM is essentially the amount of
money a channel gets for every 1000
views and will be conservative and put
their CPM at $2 the next step would be
to estimate how many views they get per
month we don't know the names of all 140
YouTube channels so we have to work
based on the subscriber count and how
long the company has been in operation
the oldest English Channel seems to be
made no earlier than 2016 but the sole
publishing is thought to be a Russian
company as many of the ad purchases with
Facebook and Google have been in rubles
as a result some of their channels and
other languages may be much older
however as all of the English channels
were created in or after 2016 we'll say
the average age of their channels is 5
years to figure out the total views
we're going to have to estimate the
average subscriber to tall channels
views ratio for instance five minute
crafts has 60 6.8 million subscribers
and about 18 billion views this means
that they have approximately 260 times
as many views across your channel as
they do subscribers
for a bright side this factor is 185
0.74 actually happened this factor is a
whopping 384 and for seven cycles this
factor is 285 generally it seems like
they have 200 to 300 times as many views
as I do subscribers which is actually
really bad as it shows that they have a
really low subscriber conversion rate as
this means that on average only 1 out of
every 200 and 300 viewers actually
subscribed to their channels to get a
conservative estimate will put the
result at all a view ratio at 150 this
means that with 420 million subscribers
they have at least 63 billion views
across their company with the ratio of
250 they would actually cost a 100
billion view mark but even after 63
billion view mark they would have
generated roughly 125 million dollars in
just ad revenue over the past 5 years or
about 25 million dollars per year of
course that's just revenue and they
surely have sky-high production costs as
well as they produce 90 videos every
single day it's likely that their
production cost is lower than 25 million
dollars per year but we'll just say that
as 25 million as this is really nothing
in comparison to their video sponsors
the soil publishing can put a product in
front of 12 Billy nice every single year
which is more than a human population
itself generally radio sponsors pay
between 5 and 10 cents per view but even
at a measly 1 cent per view the soil
publishing can put 120 million dollars
in pure profit per year as all their
production costs are more than covered
by just absence itself with a more
realistic sponsorship cost the soil
publishing can generate 600 million
dollars per year in profit and up to 1
billion dollars in a single year with
the price to earnings ratio of 10 this
means the company would be worth 6 to 10
billion dollars they don't really have
many real sponsors right now as they
have really just concentrated on growing
and understanding their audience over
the past few years
they are starting to accept sponsors for
instance they have an advertised page on
their website and it details the reach
and demographic of some of their most
popular channels and you can contact
them for pricing information but even if
they didn't go the video sponsor route
and just try to cash out right now they
could easily sell the media company for
billions for instance Facebook bought
Instagram for 1 billion dollars when
they had 30 million users and zero
revenue
similarly Facebook bought whatsapp for
19 billion and they had 450 million
monthly active users and again minimal
revenue the sole publishing has a
similar amount of subscribers at 420
million and already bring in tens of
millions of dollars in revenue of course
those acquisitions were largely overpaid
for in order to eliminate competition
but even at 1/10 of the whatsapp
valuation the sole publishing will be
worth one point nine billion dollars so
there's really no question whether or
not the sole publishing is a billion
dollar company currently they reach the
valuation based on basically any
valuation method whether price earnings
ratio or comparing them to similar
buyouts and that's not even taking into
account there are other social media
accounts like their Facebook accounts
which we should other 260 million people
but there is one large challenge for the
company the other overall views per
month and subscribers per month are
likely still going up every month due to
up-and-coming channels in their
portfolio many of their established
channels have actually experienced sharp
declines 5minute crafts pulled in 860
million views at their peak which has
since been reduced at 180 million views
similarly seven-second riddles has
dropped from 78 million to 16 million
views a month and actually happened has
a drop from 159 million views a month to
16 million views a month if you're
interested in the explanation behind
these losses then consider checking out
my video on the death of clickbait on
youtube but that's the state of the
company today only time will tell if
they maintained a billion dollar
valuation or end up like BuzzFeed
did you guys think a YouTube company
could be worth billions comment that
down below and drop a like if this video
finally explained who is behind all of
these clickbait channels and consider
subscribing to see more questions to
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one